put in a bow and it has to be the
hottest thing ever you don't want to
live some horrible lead some horrible
cliffhanger but you don't want you know
it's also a comedy and you want these
characters to live on
I just turned 46 it seemed like the
right time and life to go okay what's
next
mom you posted a great picture of the
two of you together and saying we
started to look like each other what can
we expect from tonight's hour-long
finale it's emotional filled with easter
eggs and has a final scene that even the
live studio audience didn't get to see
it's great we'll take credit yeah it's
bad we will blame all right here's the
guys apartment
for a we're close to the end of TV's
biggest show so can you blame us for
saying we know you've already given us
young Sheldon but could there be another
spin-off all my bosses are here tonight
so maybe bring it up with them it's
certainly been discussed a lot Chuck
came and said let's do it I'd say yes
other than that I don't see a spin-off
for myself but Chuck always I don't like
to say no to Chuck so if he wanted it I
meant of course there's many more
unanswered questions and we need closure
fans we never found out what Penny's
made me know now it she's Penny
Hofstadter yeah but that's not good
enough for some people I'll say then
they're like yeah yeah but what is the
maiden name but the biggest mystery
what's up with the elevator we've seen
it work once just before Leonard broke
it with a science experiment what'd you
do that for I had plenty of time
you're welcome here's my suggestion for
a finale we all fall down the elevator
ya know but everybody gets it and
actually works I know that the elevator
warrior thing and you go away yeah we go
straight up there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]